well for months and months Democrats
screech that it was a national
imperative to impeach and remove the
president they didn't want to do what
they said they were praying very hard
almost constantly fasting and prayer
ashes and sack cloth but it simply had
to be done people of faith one of the
president pieced so they did they
impeached him and then suddenly like in
a day Democrats lost interest in
impeachment in fact they've refused to
forward the articles of impeachment to
the Senate as they required to do
constitutionally now Senator Josh Hawley
of Missouri is proposing that the Senate
summarily dismissed the articles passed
by the house because they're not
prosecuting them the whole thing is
bizarre what does it mean trey Gowdy is
the man to answer that question of
course a former congressman and
prosecutor who's up your honor he joins
us tonight thanks so much for coming on
so where would you sir assess where we
are now well I understand the Senators
frustration the house is constitutional
prerogative is over but these
impeachment articles are sitting
somewhere and legislative purgatory if I
were a senator and I won't be but if I
were I would file a motion to assume
jurisdiction and set a trial date I
would do both things assume jurisdiction
so it doesn't remain in this
constitutional penumbra which is where
it is now set a trial date for a week
from today and say mr. Schiff if you're
proud of your work product show up and
present the case to the jury if you
don't show up Monday we're gonna assume
that you weren't serious about it to
begin with and then we'll file the
motion to dismiss I wouldn't make the
Cory Gardner's of the world and the
martha mcsally's vote to dismiss before
i gave them a chance to acquire
jurisdiction and set a a day certain for
the trial to begin a week from today
what's the thinking do you think of in
Pelosi's office right now I mean is it
just that they didn't want to impeach
AOC Forrester to essentially and then
she decided was hurting them so they
stopped is that what happened I think
there's a couple things Tucker I never
thought this was about removing Donald
Trump from office because that's not
going to happen I think it was always
about neutering his second term by
taking the Senate
and you know there are a couple of ways
to provide oversight in our culture one
is with the voters but that happens
irregularly it'll happen again in
November but in the meantime it's the
media's job to provide that oversight
I'll give you a dollar for every
negative story you have read about Nancy
Pelosi sitting on articles of
impeachment and a constitutionally
unprecedented way I hadn't seen a word
of criticism I've seen her lauded as a
as a tactician but no criticism about
this legislative purgatory she has the
country end no to the chills at the
Washington Post it's like you know it's
whatever it takes they don't care
thank you times for that was a great and
clear explanation we appreciate it thank
you sir thank you